hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsensors.com so in this video i
want to make something a bit different
i won't be starting from a chart where i
already have all my indicators and where
i already
built all my levels of support and
resistance
but i'm going to start from scratch and
try to explain to you guys
how to do technical analysis from the
very beginning
let's get into it
all right so i start with a chart of the
s p 500 for example
and as you can see i don't have anything
on this chart so i'm using trading view
so we even gonna start from even before
when you go on trading view
okay you arrive here you go to charts
and then you can choose
here any kind of security so spx for
example but you can choose as well euro
usd as you can see
bitcoin you have everything you need
here to make technical analysis
so let's do it on the s p 500 okay so
this is
you know all my drawings because it's
saved on the s p 500 let's start from
scratch all right so here i don't have
anything
here you can go to settings if you don't
like uh the settings the way they are
i for example prefer to be in doc and i
like to have
a gradient from dark blue to black right
this is for me more like a trading
um style all right so then you need to
add
first thing moving averages so moving
averages
are basically indicators so you can
click here
so depending on the subscription you
chose on trading view
you won't be able to use more than three
or five indicators
but i think that for a decent price i
think the first subscription
is around 10 to 15 us dollar amounts you
already can use a lot of them you just
can't combine them all together
which is not an issue so for example
here i want moving averages
so moving so just type you know moving
average and let's see what you have so
you have the exponential one
the weighting one or the simple one i
like the simple one but actually guys
uh up to you to choose exponential or
weighted and then
you need to see where you have the more
reactions you know
if an indicator has a lot of reactions
in the past then it means that this is
the one that is working the best
in this kind of security so me i i like
simple moving averages so i'm going to
choose
one two three of them
okay so here i have my three so it's
three times the same and then i'm gonna
uh modify so i go to settings
then lengths i like to have 20
i do the same here a 50 so it's a 50
period moving average
and the most used one by traders
guys it's the 200 one this one is used
as um as a as an indicator by big asset
managers
and for example when you have the 20 and
the 50
on the same chart so here let me change
the color
all right okay
so the so the purple one and the yellow
one it's the 50 and
200 it's what we call the golden cross
guys this golden cross
when the 50 crosses the 200 moving
period average
it gives uh signals of buying or selling
that i followed by
a lot of big money investors
all right like blackrock for example any
kind of
big asset manager they follow this
so we're gonna add one more indicator
that for me is crucial is the macd
right so you add the macd all right
so the macd for those who don't know
what it is so basically you have three
curves
here the blue line so it's 48
45.8 right now then you have
the exponential moving average of the
macd itself
which is a nine day exponential moving
average uh
to to have like a smoothed macd and the
signal is given by the crossover of
those two
lines so for example the difference is
here in green
or red so if it's red it's mean uh
the macd is trading below its moving
average
so the blue line is the macd here
and if it goes above here you have the
cross
then the macd signal becomes green and
it's a buying signal and the signal is
given by this but you can't follow just
um you know
stupidly this signal it is not enough i
did some back tests on the macd signals
it's basically generating a nice two
percent yearly
but is but the sharp ratio which is the
performance divided by
the volatility is not good because the
volatility of your pnl
is very high so the macd is not usable
just by itself
but you're gonna see how i like to use
it it's actually for me a nice indicator
to be associated
with the market with the price action of
the market because you it can give you
some signals uh some early signals of
reversals which are called
divergence all right i'm gonna go
through dive entrances
uh very deeply in a few my futures video
but for now just keep in mind that the
macd is very
useful when it's associated to the price
action and not
just to be used by itself so here i have
my chart i have all i need
i don't like to use rsi or stochastic
those things are
actually to me they can be useful but
all the information they have is already
here you just need to know how to read
it
so i don't like to to get my chats busy
with a lot of things
that actually then would just uh
make your mind not clear about the
signals you see
so then let's focus first on the
moving averages so i want to find what
so i'm on the daily time frame so for
example i want to find
what are the ones that that have the
most reactions
so what i can see for example is that
the 200 period moving average
look how beautiful are the reactions i
have for example here
so you see in 2016 july 1 2
3 4 five six
so you know i can zoom in a little bit
here but as you can see
the whole year we had multiple
reactions each time it was a success if
you were buyer under 200 period moving
average with this tight stop plus just
below
you would have generated a lot of
profits so this is telling me that the
200 period moving average
is very good to use so the simple one is
very good to use on the chart of the s p
500
for long term investments so basically
uh if you trade above
you wait for a retest and then you buy
it so for example here
i won't be a buyer here guys you know as
a long-term investor
investment i would be a buyer if the
price comes
back to the 200 period moving average
here i would be a buyer
here i would be a buyer uh i'm not a
buyer at 36.50
all right for short term yes but we're
going to go to the short term as well
but for the long term i'm not a buyer
here so this is how you can use the
moving averages you know they can give
you some signals
that are to be quite clear of buying and
selling and they tell you what is the
momentum of the market
if you trade above the momentum is
positive it's also given by the macd
usually those
this goes together sometimes not those
are divergences
but here it's the case so now if i go on
the shorter term so let's focus on what
is happening
for example here and let's see which
moving average
is playing as support or resistance
okay try to see with me guys trying to
see with me
definitely the 50 is useless
right you can see it has almost no
reactions no clear reactions
but the 20 20 has a reaction here
reaction here then it got broken all
right
you see guys look like the 20 is playing
a nice roll of
resistance first rejected
quite brutally by the way you know it's
like
six percent all right this is serious so
reject it brutally
then we re-test and then we blow
right through it with a massive move up
and
once it's tested it goes higher here you
have
kind of a bell trap but whatever
we have already two nice reactions
then here one two three kind of you know
not very clear uh reactions here this
was very messy this
this was full of bear traps uh i
remember here uh i i was thinking the
market
would go actually lower for other
reasons for some trend lines
reasons but the mag the 50 moving the 20
period moving average would
give you some false signals here as well
but you don't care
you know you if you have a stop loss you
just lose one
two three but here you would have if you
are if you risk reward that's why it's
important to get a big
risk reward at least above three you can
lose lose three times and win only once
and then
you are profitable i mean you're not
losing money you know you're right only
25 percent of the time
is enough not to lose money so this
would work here and then look here
one reaction two reactions three
reactions and look
what move you could take so guys this is
only by using
you know very basic moving averages 14
all right maybe you would have take your
profits before but whatever here you
make money guys if you just follow
you know the very basic uh use of
moving averages okay this is the
kind of easiest thing you can do this is
for beginners
and this is already very efficient and
can generate
big profits then let's keep
like checking what is happening on this
20 period moving average so here
if you play uh the the rebound all right
you got you got stopped but here then
you can you are below you can play
the the move down so you see same thing
once uh
support is broken it becomes resistance
and here look
support broken retest resistance and
then bam
we go lower again nice profits guys to
capture
six percent seriously in a matter of
like one week
right some like intraday traders would
love to have this kind of returns and
they use
much more complicated stuff this is the
very basic and once again
i can guarantee that the 20 or the 50 or
the 200 would work but i can what i can
guarantee you guys
if on the chart it has worked well in
the past
year two years then there is a high
probability
it works well again in the coming month
years all right this is technical
analysis this is how it works
so here let's keep checking the 20 what
kind of signals it gives us
here bullish so here okay you missed
this one you missed this one
so basically you miss one two three four
five six seven
you miss seven seven trades and you can
make
so one two no just
not this one no two three
four five
five and and here you would be a buyer
all right around 36.30 and look guys
this is exactly what i said in my uh
analysis on the s p 500 i did yesterday
i said i'm a buyer at 36 30 and i didn't
use the the 20 period moving average i
use
different tools but it all goes to the
same thing all right
so when you have different indicators
that give you the same information
then it's more it's more likely to be
true to happen
all right so for the moving averages i
think i'm done
i mean you know it's not rocket science
it's not more complicated than this
you just check those that work well in
the past
days weeks month depending on the time
frame you want to trade
and then you uh make your you build some
trades
by but you wait for the for the price to
trade above and then you buy the retest
all right with the tight stop loss this
is what you guys need to do to make
profits
here you would have have uh half winners
half losers but with risk reward around
three to
five so basically you would have
generated a lot of profits
okay and this market was not easy we
need to use
for example trend lines to make some
obvious
let's start with easy you know some
obvious areas
of support and resistance so for example
i would use here you know
it's just about connecting the highs and
lows of what you see
and see if it makes sense you know it
seems it is exactly the same as moving
averages
if you don't have a lot of reactions
then it means nobody's
nobody cares about it then it means that
the other investors are not
using it so here for example i can do
a nice trend line here guys you see bam
and why i like this one because i have
one
two three four reactions
all right on a two year chart
so it's a lot all right it's a lot so
this one is
of course nice to use and once you have
this
it's going to work you know for a long
time you know
because this is a two-year move guys so
to your move
has a lot of inner c you know it has a
lot of um
to be to go against this kind of move
you need a lot of things to happen in
the markets
investors think differently but for now
this is the trend
this is like kind of the the highest uh
scenario that can happen to the s p 500
and it goes to 3 800 in may 21.
so all those who say yeah like i heard
for example goldman sachs saying we're
going to have an s p 500 at 4
000 200 something like this in the
middle of next year
i don't believe it because of this you
know so this is just to create grid in
the market guys
i don't know where they get the
information but i can tell you that the
s p
won't be trading above 4 000 before next
june
all right because i mean you never know
what will happen but it's very unlikely
and how i know it just by doing a trend
line all right
then what all the what other trend line
you see so let's make some horizontal
ones
so you need to find some pivot points
all right
so here i have a maximum and you can see
that here i have some minimum
so if i just do like this then
i have one two three four five reactions
nice five reactions i like it i know
this is
very visible a lot of people use it
especially it's a horizontal trend line
so everybody
always agrees on the horizontal trend
lines you know they're not tricky
they're very obvious to see and
definitely look
the 200 period moving average will be
trading here around then or fab
so guys i was talking about a massive
correction of the school move up
and i know where potentially it would go
to the 200 period moving average because
it always comes back to the 200 period
moving average
if i take this chart on the very long
term we are never far
from the 200 period moving average we
can you know be extended
a bit for a while even for one year but
ultimately we come back to it
and we retest it all right this is how
things happen
forever it has been like this it's still
gonna be like this
so if you are too far from your 200
period moving average it means you are
too much extended
this is the same information you would
have in the rsi guys
why would you need to use rsi when you
can just see it it's visual
all right here i would be a buyer like i
mean
in the long term i would be a massive
buyer at 3200 level when the 200 period
moving average will be there as well so
i have a double signal
all right then if you want to go a bit
deeper
you can use idiots all right so
illiot is another level so i'm just
gonna go very
quickly through this here but once you
have
identified some resistance some support
so moving using the moving averages
using trend lines
then you kind of need to understand
what is happening in this market and
where are we heading
and where are we in terms of development
of the waves
and so we take illiot all right so i
take
uh one two three four five
and i try to make to measure five waves
in this move up all right
so one two
three four and five
so idiot wave theory is not easy so
basically it's about
uh understanding where we are in terms
of development
of the waves so for example you have
some uh
tricks that help you to uh do your
counting
uh this the third wave must be the most
impulsive one the most strongest
like the strongest one so so here
definitely you know this
is a three because you can see how
powerful this move up was
so when you have this kind of move you
know that this must be a third wave
uh and then you never know it's if
actually the whole move is finished
so for example this is when we need to
combine
trend line and eliot way formation for
example here
i wasn't sure if it was a three or maybe
if it was like this
it could have been like this guys you
know one two three four five and then
here i have a correction
and i was thinking this might be the
case
but what told me this scenario is off
the table
is actually when we broke here
you see when we broke this trend line
and the upside retested it retested it i
was a strong buyer here this was my
first video i did on this channel
uh when i predicted uh that there was
gonna be a strong bull
uh rally um a strong rally in the coming
months and this was one month ago so i
was right about that
and and i'm pretty sure them right as
well when i said that we're gonna have a
massive correction
in jan or february maybe february or
march
doesn't mean the end is gonna be bloody
just means there's gonna be a massive
correction maybe then
things are gonna go better i don't know
i'm just telling you guys that this move
up is almost done
and this i know because i use iliad all
right then another interesting thing
about iliad guys if you want to know
if a wave is finished or not
or if a whole move is about to be done
or not
then you can use the macd as a leading
indicator to be associated with the
price action
that we call divergence all right so let
me show you guys what is the divergence
and how i would be using it here
so as i said i identified
that we are probably in the fifth wave
of iliad formation
especially that usually fifth wave are
weak
so for example a diagonal is weaker than
an impulse
uh and and you have some signals that
the market might be shifting soon
like a divergence so let's go to a
divergence so
to find one you need to take a momentum
indicator so here's the macd
you measure the high do two highs
between a period so here i have a high
at 80
and here i have a high at 60. all right
during this time the market went from so
i take the exact same time guys
here to here
so the market went higher so this is a
divergence you see
the the price action is bullish we go
higher but
the momentum indicator is shifting down
so you have already some
information about the flows that are
reverting that
there are some profit takings and maybe
even some short positions getting built
in this market
and trust me they are probably even if
everybody is bullish
you know some guys the smart money has
already
i think gone uh from the massive flows
we had
here the smart money was here invested
here
and the smart money is now offloading
the positions
i think so you can even have a
divergence even bigger here
from here to here
all right but this takes two waves
in in one move it's not easy to to read
information in this
but anyway you can see that the market
is losing steam
for example here you have the same
divergence between here and here here
and here
so that's why we went lower and actually
the market
got some fresh energy back at the 3200
level and it went higher ultimately
but what i'm saying is that when you
have those kind of patterns associated
here we didn't have any anti-diagonal
this was an impulse guys
all right what we have here is very
different
it's an ending diagonal for those who
don't know what is an ending diagonal
please click on the link in the
description of the video and where
and you're going to receive a free video
that i'm actually doing right now it's
going to be amazing where i explain
everything every techniques that you can
use in illiot wave principle
uh to actually find out where we are
in terms of wave development you have
some tricks for example like a zigzag
in a in a five wave move up if the
second
corrective wave is a zigzag then usually
the force corrective wave
is a flat zigzag flat alright
so here it worked and it works actually
uh
quite often here we have a combination
of
divergence between the price action and
the macd together with an ending
diagonal
that is actually converging at the
the trendline resistance level that is
lasting for the past two years so i have
three kind of information together that
tell me that
in jan or fab the market is going to
reverse badly
all right so nothing 100 sure
nothing guaranteed but this is what my
tools are giving me
so i repeat very quickly what you need
to get on your charts is moving averages
20 50 to 100 simple weighted exponential
it's as you wish
just you know i showed you guys how to
change it you just go to settings
and you can change the you know
the um the time uh
for example do close high open whatever
you have all the different features here
and you choose the ones that have worked
the best in the past
weeks month years because usually
they're gonna keep be being the ones
that are working the best
then you build some support areas uh
some
some areas of support and resistance by
using trend lines
uh the most basic one horizontal or even
sloping it's fine
and then you use iliad wave principle to
kind of
know where you are in terms of
development
of the waves and where this market is it
might be heading
you can associate this with some
momentum indicator and trying to find
some divergences
so hope i managed to make myself clear
this is
not that simple but trust me guys if you
practice this
on a daily even weekly basis you know if
you just use your brain
to to your mind to to like kind of you
know find
the right counting it's not going to be
correct the very first time for sure
but with time it's going to be even more
and more
obvious for you guys to understand what
are the wave formation so that's it for
me thank you guys and stay close to shaw